foreign
welcome to the press conference
following our 29th EU Japan Summit
just let me remind you that we have
translation into Japanese English and
French for those following remotely
we're about to publish the statement
that was adopted and I first give the
flow to the president of the European
Council please thank you good afternoon
prime minister kishida
it's a pleasure to welcome you here in
Brussels today Japan and EU Corporation
is a strong and positive server and I
would like to thank you dear fumio the
Prime Minister for your leadership and
personally for your friendship Japan is
one of the EU strongest allies in Japan
is our closest partner in the
indo-pacific region today we agreed to
work for greater security and prosperity
for our people and to generate more
opportunities for our businesses our
shared values are the pet work of our
relationship democracy rule of flow and
multilateral cooperation
Japan's support to people of Ukraine has
been impressive as the current G7 share
you have stood resolutely in back in
Ukraine and condemning Russia and just
yesterday in real news we G7 leaders
committed to Rampage up our support for
Ukraine and increasing the pressure on
Russia
the EU and Japan are also working
together to bolster peace and security
on the Korean Peninsula North Korea's
nuclear program and westless missile
tests like the one used to do threaten
Regional and International Security we
condemn this in the strongest possible
terms the indo-pacific is a vibrant and
ruined region a key player in shaping
wfs in the EU we are stepping up our
engagement with CR region
our 27 member states are united on China
recently the European Council reformed
his multifaceted approach both China and
the EU have an interest in stable and
translative relationship we will engage
to tackle Global challenges but these
are issues that need to be addressed
Level Playing Field reciprocity and a
balanced economic relationship we will
diversify and the risk we appropriate
we'll always promote our values and our
interests today we agree to deepen our
exchanges on all these issues we are
also taking the step forward in our
operational security and we agreed to
launch a strategic dialogue that will
also include security and defense and
this will boost our cooperation in areas
like Maritime security or cyber and
hybrid threats
today we also identify key projects that
will help us achieve our green and
digital roles like the hydropower
storage project in Vietnam that will
assist in phasing out toll and driving
forward the green transition
or the northern Corridor project in East
Africa that will improve trade and
transport connectivity in that region
economic resilience is a top priority
for both Japan and the EU we agreed to
step up our strategic operation to
reinforce our supply chains especially
in critical raw materials like where
Earth
the EU and Japan are also powerful
engines in protecting our planet in the
run-up 2018 we agreed to cooperate more
in areas that will drive forward our
green transition like Solar Supply
chains offshore wind grid technology and
Energy Efficiency and you are also
boosting cooperation on hydrogen
production
ladies and gentlemen just last year
bilateral trade between Japan and the EU
increased more than 13 and now we are
building on that momentum we
specifically discussed improving Market
access and today the EU agreed to again
allow the import of products from the
Fukushima region EU fools will also get
better access to Japanese markets this
is another sign of trust and cooperation
dear prime minister kishida the fumio
Japan and the European Union share a
genuine bond that we can be proud of we
are reliable Partners we are reliable
friends for greater peace and Security
in the world and it will continue I
thank you
thank you Mr President Madam president
you have the flu thank you very much
thank you Charles thank you prime
minister defundi from you yesterday we
were together in Vilnius as partners at
the NATO Summit we discussed our
cooperation in Europe and the
indo-pacific and today we are here
together in Brussels at the EU Japan
Summit a very clear message of
partnership and friendship
we share with Japan the analysis that
from Ukraine to the indo-pacific
the world is one security theater
and also in real news the G7 and Japan's
presidency
and the European Union made very clear
that security commitments to Ukraine are
vital We Stand by Ukraine as we have
done since the beginning of the Russian
aggression
at the same time with our indo-pacific
strategy we are also increasing our
engagement in the region because we know
that indo-pacific security and European
security are indivisible
and I'm pleased that we are launching a
strategic dialogue to coordinate on
these unprecedented challenges to peace
and security
and this includes of course also the
vital topic of Economic Security this is
my first point
we've seen supply chain disruption
caused by the pandemic and Russia's
invasion in Ukraine we've seen cyber
attacks and economic coercion all that
has been a wake-up call for us
Economic Security is of vital importance
and a common concern
we agreed to coordinate on these issues
at the G7 level and now we are launching
a bilateral Dialogue on economic
security as well
as you all know Japan is a front-runner
in this area
we the European Union have just
developed our own Economic Security
strategy
so I believe that we have a lot to gain
from working together on this topic
we share similar dependencies
we both need see the need to de-risk our
supply chains
so one of our objectives is to reduce
over Reliance on a handful of suppliers
many of them based in China
for products that are vital for our
economies
for instance critical raw materials
I'm very pleased that we are concluding
a cooperation Arrangement on raw
materials between the European
commission and Japan
the same goes for semiconductors
and I'm glad that we have also concluded
a memorandum of cooperation on the issue
of semiconductors
it will cover for example monitoring the
supply chains it will cover the very
important aspects of research and of
course the UN
um the the important aspect of advanced
skills for this industry's skilled
Personnel is badly needed
the second point that I want to
emphasize is that we have taken stock of
our economic partnership agreement it is
now enforced since four years
and it is delivering
trade flows have increased by 20 percent
and this despite the covet pandemic
but we also know that we can do much
more
therefore on our side the European Union
side we agreed to lift the remaining
restrictive import measures
that were linked to the Fukushima
accident
we have taken this decision based on
science
and based on the proof of evidence
and based on the assessment of the
international atomic energy agency
and we also agreed to solve several
other trade issues in the course of this
year in particular the access for our
agricultural products to the Japanese
Market
the third topic I want to mention is the
stepping up our cooperation on digital
we have launched our digital partnership
a year ago
since then we have made good progress on
connectivity
for example an exciting project that is
we will deploy an Arctic submarine cable
that delivers high capacity and secure
connections between Europe and Japan
and now we go one step further
we will work on 6G we will work on high
performance Quantum Computing and cyber
security so the whole agenda of the
digital partnership is growing and is
getting more dense and concrete
most importantly we will cooperate on
artificial intelligence this has two
legs of course on one hand we want to
reap its benefits
but on the other hand we also see the
risks and we want to manage the risks
my first point is on clean tech and the
energy transition for that we have our
green Alliance it's the first screen
aligns the European Union ever concluded
here with Japan and now we are teaming
up to deploy renewable energy
in particular offshore wind and clean
hydrogen in Europe and in Japan
and in parallel we are investing
together in sustainable infrastructure
around the world on the European Union
side this is our investment program you
are well aware of global gateway
and there's a similar investment program
on the Japanese side together
we are showing results for example from
a hydropower storage project in Vietnam
to railway infrastructure in Indonesia
or to transport corridors in Africa just
to name a few examples
finally I shared our experience with
carbon pricing which is a very good way
to reduce emissions while generating
revenues for the clean energy transition
and it was interesting to hear the plans
on the Japanese side
so in conclusion it was an excellent
Summit with tangible outcomes we need
each other more than ever for our
security and our economic resilience and
we are closer than ever thank you very
much
thank you madam president prime minister
kishida you have the flu
thank you
I am immensely pleased that today upon
visiting Brussels president Michelle of
the European Council president Wonder
Lion of the European commission and
myself met in person for the annual
Japan EU Summit
first the decision by the EU to lift
import restrictions on Japanese food
will provide strong support to the
Reconstruction of the affected area the
government of Japan highly values and
welcomes the decision
the views agreed upon at the G7
Hiroshima Summit that any unilateral
attempt to change status quo by force is
unacceptable anywhere in the world
and that we shall continue to work
closely towards maintaining and
strengthening a free and open
International order based on the rule of
law were again reaffirmed at today's
meeting
especially as we Face a severe security
environment we welcome the stronger
engagement by the EU in the
india-pacific
Japan and the EU will establish a
strategic dialogue at the foreign
ministerial level and further strengthen
cooperation in extensive areas including
security
we agree to deepen our dialogue and
cooperation in Economic Security as well
the economic security strategy released
by the EU on the 20th of June is based
on fundamental principles common to
Japan's basic position on Economic
Security
and is highly appreciated by the
government of Japan
we also welcome the new administrative
Arrangement established on this occasion
on cooperation over critical raw
materials
it is important to build on such
concrete cooperation
based on our agreement at last year's
annual Summit to launch a Japan EU
digital partnership
the council meeting was held among
relevant ministers on the third of this
month and then on the next day the
fourth of this month the memorandum of
cooperation between Japan and the EU on
salmon conductors was signed these are
Milestones that we very much welcome
also
rapid development and take up of AI
especially generative AI is an important
challenge with the EU as well as for
entire International Community
I will convey in this Autumn G7 leaders
online meeting
centering around the theme of generic
generative AI
through Hiroshima AI process agreed at
G7 Hiroshima Summit
at the G7 presidency country we will
lead International discussions on
generative AI
further
building on Japan EU partnership on
sustainability
sustainable connectivity and quality
infrastructure
projects were identified for Japan EU
Corporation
from the perspective of strengthening
engagement with global South
as well
we will step up our cooperation with EU
also based on green Alliance
strengthening cooperation
further in climate change energy as well
as in global health was Affirmed
especially in hydrogen area a number of
Cooperative projects are already ongoing
such as technology development
cooperation in automobile area and
cooperation in green hydrogen production
to strengthen these efforts Japan EU
Cooperative framework will be launched
at the latest level with pillars
Alba industry finance and Technology
with the leaders involvement
Japan EU are top Runners on hydrogen
area
by advancing rulemaking
for hydrogen distribution Global rollout
of technology and production and
building large-scale supply chain
hydrogen Society
will be realized
toward achieving carbon neutrality
conventional and international situation
candidate exchange abuse took place
in responses to Russia's Federation
against Ukraine to end the aggression as
swiftly as possibly can
continuation of severe sanctions
against Russia and strong support for
Ukraine and engagement with countries
including Global South
to respond in much more reinforced way
in unity amongst the International
Community where we are firmed on China
importance was affirmed on director
communication with China on a common
concern and seeking to act as a
responsible member of the International
Community working together with China on
global challenges like climate change
and common areas of our interest
and building constructive and stable
relations through dialogue
or North Korea
yesterday on the 12th ICBM class
ballistic missile was launched
like seeing there there is a increased
nuclear and missile activities on the
part of North Korea where we share the
great concern
and
in responses to North Korea including
abduction issue Japan and EU will work
together closely was affirmed to be able
to issue joint statement as an outcome
of today's Summit would be a very
significant message to the vision
and to the International Community
I will remain in close cooperation with
President Mitchell of the European
Council and president of hondalian of
the European commission thank you
thank you prime minister for your
remarks we'll first be taking a couple
of questions from the Japanese media and
we have a question from TV Asahi yes
please
thank you very much
I have a question to prime minister
kishida
each of the leaders mentioned the
lifting of the import restrictions
against Japanese food
the decision on lifting the restrictions
was adopted this restriction continued
for a long time what kind of discussion
took place that had led to this decision
to lift the restrictions on a related
topic
the government will shortly begin the
discharge of treated water to the Sea
were there any discussions on this
matter and if yes were you able to gain
the understanding of the EU another
major agenda item for this meeting was
Economic Security
mentioned the words China and in the
economic security context
how will Japan cooperate with the EU and
partner with the EU in Economic Security
thank you
thank you very much
you asked three questions to myself and
let me respond to those questions first
of all
on the
decision to lift import restrictions on
Japanese food
at the annual Japan EU Summit held
moments ago
president founder Lion of the European
commission briefed this on the decision
by the EU to lift the import restriction
to date the government of Japan has been
taking every opportunity available to
call upon the EU and its member states
at all levels to lift the restrictions
sooner than later the decision by the EU
will push forward the recovery and
reconstruction of the affected area
and it is based upon science robust
science so we very much value and
welcome that decision
on upstrated water
you also asked me a question on that
on opposituated water
Japan explained that from the
perspective of the construction
from Great Eastern Japan earthquake
ocean discharge of offshooted water is
important and second while being
reviewed by iaea based on scientific
evidences Japan is responding in
transparent Manner and three
is a comprehensive report
it concluded that ocean discharge is
consistent with International standards
and impact is negligible on people and
environment
EU
welcomes that Japan is responding in a
transparent way and iaea Report was
announced
in the jointed statement this time also
these points will be iterated your third
point about the economic security
so with regard to The Economic Security
Economic Security strategy announced by
EU
converges with the basic thought of
Japan on the economic security
we welcome this direction as like my day
countries and partners
on supply chain and critical
infrastructure resilience
responses to economic coalition
and
appropriate management of sensitive
technology it's important that Japan and
EU and like-minded countries
coordinate and respond in one voice to
Economic Security as well as toward the
disking
and take necessary measures steadily and
in the sense importance is attached to
G7 framework agreed at the Hiroshima
Summit
as G7 we like to deepen strategic
coordination and cooperation and
reinforce further cooperations on
individual concrete matters
based on the outcome of this Japan EU
Summit
we hope to deepen further between Japan
and EU as well
dialogue and cooperation in Economic
Security area
those are the responses I made to you on
the three points asked thank you prime
minister we have another question by
money cheap newspapers yes please
newspaper my name is tanabe thank you
very much for this opportunity
president Michelle and president
Wonderland I have questions to you
regarding the lifting of the decision on
food imports you said decided decision
was handed down what will be the timing
when the lifting will actually be put
into Force
and what are the reasons behind the
decision to lift those restrictions and
EU and NATO
regarding China which is sought to be
close to Russia how does the EU and NATO
NATO tend to face Russia or China thank
you China that is close to Russia
on your first point a dialogue began a
while ago with the Japanese authorities
to lift the import restrictions and
prime minister kishida I think perfectly
summed up the state of our relations and
our work on this we base ourselves on
objective data and particularly the
report of the international atomic
energy Authority it's on the basis of
that we decided to lift restrictions and
now we have to implement this decision
make sure it's operational now in
parallel to that I also point out that
with the Japanese authorities we are
working to facilitate access of
agricultural products beef fruit and
vegetable in particular access of EU
these EU products to Japan so that's the
first point your second question about
the EU and NATO well of course a
cooperation between the EU and NATO has
been strengthened significantly and
several initiatives have been taken also
between Japan and NATO and I think this
shows that we believe that the security
challenges are Global in nature and we
are always partners with those who
believe in a rule-based world and who
face the same challenges as us we are
facing a challenge because of the war
that was triggered by Russia against the
Ukraine where also facing challenges uh
such as the instability and insecurity
created by North Korea
so together we have to work to prevent
threats to our stability and our
security both in Europe and in the
indo-pacific
first question the EU import restriction
measures
a link to the Fukushima accident have
always been based on scientific rounds
so now we lifted the measures as of
today
based on the latest evidence that has
been provided by Japan and this is done
with the agreement of the member states
I want to thank the Japanese authorities
because you have provided regular
updates on the Fukushima status in a
timely and in a transparent manner this
process also shows the reliability on on
both sides
in Vilnius there were many topics on the
agenda one of the topics that came up
was of course also the topic of Economic
Security
and you know the three elements that are
in our strategy dominant it is first of
all to promote
our own resilience so to increase the
resilience of our own economy this is
very important the competitiveness of
our own economy then to protect this is
basically to make sure the vast majority
of trade is completely
uncomplicated what we have to make sure
is that is a Level Playing Field for our
companies as it is reciprocal for other
companies but also to make sure that
cutting-edge technology
is not being used to increase military
capabilities somewhere else and the
third element and this is what I want to
reflect on here at the Summit is to
partner with country if we de-risk the
risk not decouple is the headline for
our concept also yesterday in the
discussion if we de-risk we have to be
well coordinated so that it does not go
at the expense of each other
and therefore for example our memorandum
of cooperation on semiconductors that we
concluded
is a brilliant example that we
coordinate in the semiconductors on the
cooperation in research
here for example the brilliant iMac that
is based in Belgium and development that
we have early warning mechanism in case
that there are critical disruptions in
Supply chains of semiconductors and of
course that we work together on the
advanced skills for the semiconductor
industry so this is a living example a
living proof for how you can in a
well-coordinated manner de-risk and work
together so that it is for the benefit
for all of us
thank you we'll be taking yes Philip
from the EU side Philly blank insert
from Reuters yeah the philippling is
above Reuters um I just wanted to have a
bit more information you mentioned
obviously in terms of food
that you'd agree to solve issues with in
relation to EU products access to
Japanese markets I think you must
Michelle mentioned beef vegetables maybe
you can just clarify what what the issue
is and then just on Economic Security in
general obviously you've got uh you know
you'll be discussing
um Supply chains diversification you
have for example a memorandum and an
understanding of semiconductors what
sort of concrete results might one
expect from this dialogue in time
foreign
it is agricultural products a certain
variety of agricultural products that
had trade barriers accessing uh the
Japanese market and here
um we hope uh and we're confident that
there will be an improvement for the
agricultural sector to access on a Level
Playing Field the Japanese Market
what the economic security is concerned
as I said Japan is a front runner Japan
was if not the first country to develop
the principles of Economic Security and
we've learned a lot from Japan where
that is concerned you also see it in our
Economic Security strategy that the
commission tabled the principle that we
developed the de-risk not decouple says
very clearly first of all de-risk
naughty couple diplomatically
so mentioned by prime minister kishida
here also in this press conference the
dialogue that has to be kept open not
only a dialogue on topics where we agree
but also our Dialogue on topics where we
disagree
to avoid misunderstandings that's Point
number one but Economic Security of
course has then a strong emphasis on the
economy
and indeed here is a variety of
different topics that you can look at it
starts with the over dependency on
certain products for example the
critical raw materials but also the
semiconductors here over dependency
means if you have one country that is
the major supplier for this critical
good that therefore has a monopoly or
quasi Monopoly on the supply of these
Goods here we agreed that we will
coordinate and partner to diversify our
supply chain so look for other suppliers
worldwide
I gave you an example
in critical raw materials
we are looking for others who are able
to provide critical raw materials for
example in Latin America
they are mining but the value chain
often is then in China so the Monopoly
for the processed Goods is in China and
our dependency High lithium 97
dependency of the European Union on
Chinese lithium while the origin is
partially in Africa or for example in
Chile or for example in Argentina
the second element that is important in
the de-risking is that as I said the
vast majority of products and goods are
without any difficulties but we if we're
looking at cutting-edge Technologies in
Quantum Computing in biotech
Cutting Edge semiconductors for example
AI there we have to be careful that we
do not have a flow of these cutting-edge
Technologies to countries that use it to
increase their military capabilities
countries where we have our concerns
and finally we have developed partially
also together
instruments that we can use for example
the instrument of foreign direct
investment the inbound investment
screening or an instrument of
anti-coherion we have seen how Lithuania
for example suffered of the coheritive
measures China was taken against has
taken against Lithuania with that the
European Union protecting Lithuania
developed the anti-coversion instrument
this shows the whole concept of Economic
Security started by Japan but now also
responded on the European side
two points very quickly on the first
question
so access of European products such the
Japanese Market that there are two main
sectors there
where we've committed
so beef and fruit and vegetables
and we are talking about phyto sanitary
as standards are there and then on
economic security well
um there's a democratic process in the
EU following on from the debates that
took place in the G7 on economic
security so the commission has presented
a communication there was an initial a
debate at the uh a European uh Council a
couple of weeks ago and we've already
mapped out to the the path forward
so we want to be proportionate uh well
targeted in our actions and we want to
maintain the benefits of an open economy
but at the same time there might be
risky situations and those risks need to
be reduced
so
um interdependence
um over-reliance over-dependence and and
that can make us more vulnerable
so over a history we've seen now the
abuse of dominant positions and the this
causes difficulties so the EU might
become a very dependent on a certain
material so strategic materials so we
have to think about what we can do to
counteract that so um this means that in
the coming year weeks and months we'll
continue with discussions um and the
commission will then make a legislative
a proposal at the end of the year
so this is a starting point for the
debate that there is still work to be
done so member states will be very much
involved in matahola process and this is
something that will also be a conducted
in close partnership with them all of
our friends and partners thank you
simple
may I say one word on this
recording
regarding the import of agricultural
products from the EU
we're happy that you made the decision
to lift import restrictions on Japanese
food this was based upon science and the
key is to make all decisions based upon
scientific expertise so the same will
apply to Japan Japan will make a
judgment and decision based upon science
on semiconductors
you also asked me a question on they say
my conductors as well with regard to
Japan EU cooperation semiconductors on
the July the Third
the Moc on the semiconductor was signed
and also at this Summit today
views conclude ON Semiconductor supply
chain cooperation r d Advanced skills as
well as the building early morning
warning mechanism to respond to
semiconductor supply chain disruption
based on the Japan EU agreement efforts
and initiatives will be taken thank you
prime minister will take last yes Stuart
we'll take a last question there
thank you very much Stuart of Politico
uh first of all a couple of questions
for prime minister kishta
um on semiconductors Japan recently
joined the U.S and the Netherlands in
imposing semiconductor restrictions
against countries including China do you
expect Japan to carry out more of these
kinds of restrictions on China
on China or other countries and do you
foresee a future where Japan will be
coordinating with the EU rather than
only a member State on this kind of
restrictions and a very quick question
on Ukraine if I'm a for the Prime
Minister uh what do you think about the
idea of using Frozen Russian assets for
the purposes of Ukraine's reconstruction
and for the two presidents on critical
minerals China recently announced export
restrictions on gallium and germanium
I'm wondering uh whether this topic came
up in the discussion today and how much
of an impact this would bring to
European businesses and would the
response be considered in the light of
anti-coercion instrument thank you
foreign
with regard to the semiconductors
as I said to you already
you
had to sign the Moc on the semiconductor
and based on that cooperation Will Go On
and this does not
suppose any certain countries in mind
it is that uh
Japan has just presented its basic
policy
meaning that we do not suppose any
certain country for having prepared this
policy I would like to remind you about
that and also you asked about gallium
and the germanium
and
going ahead
in what way
to move will be seen
well this has not been confirmed yet
it's yet to be seen China and other
relevant countries in what way they will
come up with a concrete responses is
something that we will watch very
closely
and following the closely
we like to figure out our thoughts on
what it should be thank you
only question about the announcement
made by China I think that just proves
that we're right uh for some time now
we've been saying we need to diversify
our supply chains I mean and we've
analyzed in an objective way the
consequences of this announcement what
the repercussions will be and what
possible attitude could be taken by the
EU on this but once again this just
proves that we were right in the EU and
our partners to focus on diversifying
our supply chains what the critical raw
materials gallium and germanium are
concerned China was clear that it is a
response to the semiconductor issue
um and indeed they announced that they
take the first step to put those two
critical raw materials on the list of
export controls in the first days as far
as I understand of August they will take
the decision whether to implement
um so what we do right now is and this
is a typical process in a situation like
this that we clarify who is dependent
what sector exactly is dependent on this
uh critical raw materials from China
it's the cleantech sector but they're
specific uh who has what kind of
dependency what Supply chains are
concerned and then then very important
who else is offering these materials
worldwide and how can we diversify our
supply chains
um specifically for example for these
two critical raw materials this is also
the purpose of the critical raw
materials Club
that we are in the process of forming so
that we have a faster response for this
time type of coercion that we have a
better overview who can help us step in
with supplier for example this type of
critical raw material other products
this came from the experience that we
had not only in the pandemic but also
the dependency on Russian fossil fuels
where all of a sudden Putin cut 80 of
the pipeline gas in eight months there
we learned how important it is to have
different reliable like-minded Partners
this is the process that we are now
doing to prevent these difficult
situations
thank you madam president Mr President
and prime minister kishida this
concludes our press conference thanks
again hi
can we have a joint